bindi Irwin continues to impress on and
off the dance floor before she boogie
down during the semifinals the
seventeen-year-old
opened up about life after losing her
father Steve Irwin I just always wanted
to make sure that dad's legacy carried
on a couple weeks after he passed away
and I said to mom when are we gonna stop
filming again and I thought that's so
weird that she would want to start
filming when we're right in the middle
of all this turmoil and then I realized
that was Bendis normal what she used to
always do with her dad was what she
wanted to continue doing bindi rocked
all three of her semifinal routines with
pro partner Derek Hough first up in
upbeat salsa number
then a fiery Samba Mark Ballas joined
the duo for their final dance a unique
jazz number that dazzled the judges with
straight tens
et was with bindi after the show let's
talk about Instagram this weekend
Saturday was Chandler's birthday yeah
and then sunday was international Steve
Irwin do we celebrated 10 was that they
was just eight and he came and he came
in and she's like oh it was hilarious
thing you're like trying to fix your
hair
Steve oh and a just a really a day to
remember dad and everything he worked so
hard for and so we were encouraging
everyone to wear their khakis the whole
dancing that cocky shot